my personal process is one of
maintaining a very I would say monastic
discipline I mean I essentially do the
same thing every day seven days a week
and I've done that two years besides
from the things I have to do beside from
a socialize in which I like to do
occasionally besides from traveling
which I like to do less now that I'm
older and that you have to take off your
shoes I basically go to my studio and
you know as trivial as it might seem
somebody else it's just always something
there's always a little problem that
needs to be figured out so I feel like
my studio is a laboratory you know and
you know there is a sense of alchemy
there is a sense of chemistry there is a
sense of joy there is a sense of the
pleasure that I have in playing with
this stuff paint the stuff you know that
I basically understand on some level you
could garnish it with all kinds of of
theoretical constructs but it's it's a
person alone in a room making things
with their hands and I like to keep it
that simple a lot of days and when
you're making things and when you have
your little cottage industry there's
always something to do when I go to my
studio I start out by sweeping the floor
I start out by making sure everything's
in order
I start out by trying to make sure my
mind is clear and then I think about the
problem that didn't get solved yesterday
and that opens it up for me
so I think that's the process what's the
problem today is the question I ask
myself the Roey seems to be something
I'm most happy when I I'm not distracted
when I'm working when I could go to my
studio when I somehow could live in that
presence that presence and the present
and I could do it repetitively so that
you kind of build up a steam you know
it's like a it's like an engine it's
like a it's like a percolator and
sometimes it just becomes you know it
really becomes a kind of a concentration
that's so pure that I think is both
playful and imaginative and opens up all
kinds of new possibilities